à qui a voulu créer des pagailles en
dynamisant si ça s'agite pour moi
aujourd'hui est jeune homme d'état et
ces gens là
l'histoire doit condamner en 45 en 16
tentatives de coup d'état quatre putschs
le dernier c'était en 2012 vous croyez
que c'est terminé où vous êtes en sursis
le mois gêne aucun opposant aujourd'hui
guinée-bissau aujourd'hui il a un seul
chef chez moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
si on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si c'est interdit d'interdire
18 maires de droite réclament
l'extension des pouvoirs de leur police
municipale tribune d'élus aujourd'hui
dans le jdd 24 heures après le
déplacement de jean castex à nice la
ville azuréenne touché par de récents
violent deux récents épisodes violents
le premier ministre a annoncé plusieurs
mesures de proximité pour lutter contre
l'insécurité et appelle à la vigilance
pour éviter une deuxième pacte
coronavirus
[Musique]
le 3 novembre c'est dans 100 jours
l'élection présidentielle américaine
s'annonce incertaine en toile de fond
christelle iter et contestation sociale
le mouvement black alive sneijder ne
faiblit pas à l'instar des heures à
seattle tout comme portland cette ville
de la côte ouest est secouée par des
heurts entre forces de l'ordre et
manifestants anti violence policière
tensions toujours à très forte entre
athènes et ankara 48 heures après la
première prière de milliers de musulmans
depuis la reconversion de l'ex basilique
byzantine sainte sophie
l'édifice religieux d'istanbul qui
bénéficiait du statut de musée depuis
1934 et cristallisent les relations
diplomatiques houleuses entre la turquie
et de nombreux pays comme la grèce donc
mais aussi les etats-unis la france ou
encore la russie
[Musique]
très bonne fin de week end à toutes et à
tous très heureux de vous retrouver sur
rt france pour un nouveau point complet
sur l'information et un retour sur les
faits marquants de la semaine
une convention pour renforcer leurs
prérogatives c'est ce que propose
aujourd'hui 18 maires de droite dans une
tribune du journal du dimanche
un appel qui intervient au lendemain de
la visite du premier ministre jean
castex à nice le maire ait l'air de la
ville azuréenne christian estrosi fait
partie des signataires alors que sa
commune a vécu lundi un épisode de
violence
un acte qui rappellent plusieurs
derniers événements d'incivilités dans
l'hexagone
les élus locaux appellent à agir contre
l'insécurité nous proposons au
gouvernement la signature d'une
convention entre mr procureur et préfet
dans ce cadre des pouvoirs
supplémentaires seraient confiées aux
mères volontaires et disposant d'une
administration adapté il leur ouvrirait
un accès total aux fichiers comme ceux
des permis de conduire des voitures
volées des personnes recherchées des
fiches et s et autorise rhino police
municipale a procédé à des contrôles
d'identité
un parmi les signataires également
arnaud robinet mer les républicains de
reims vous savez aujourd'hui on le voit
il y a un manque d'effectifs au niveau
de la police nationale on le voit
également des déficits au niveau des
équipements et que nos polices
municipales sont parfois mieux équipés
que la police nationale c'est un fait et
nous le constatons dans plusieurs villes
de france
aujourd'hui ce que nous demandons c'est
pouvoir avoir accès à des fichiers
fichier des immatriculations a notamment
lorsqu'il ya occupation illégale par des
gens du voyage à titre d'exemple la
question également de pouvoir verbaliser
dans le cas de la forfaitisation de la
consommation de stupéfiants ce sont deux
exemples qui doivent nous permettre de
renforcer la sécurité renforcé la
sécurité à vis de la délinquance d'une
façon générale de la petite délinquance
qui est que c'est moi du terme pourrit
la vie quotidienne de nos concitoyens
aujourd'hui donc cette proposition c'est
pour plus d'efficacité plus de
réactivité et je dirais renforcer ce
continuum de la sécurité et à police
nationale les collectivités avec la
police municipale et bien sûr la justice
et les acteurs sociaux notamment les
bailleurs sociaux dans le cadre de la
sécurité de la tranquillité résidentiel
en déplacement également à nice hier aux
côtés de jean castex gérald darmanin qui
s'est rendu aujourd'hui à saint-etienne
du rouvray près de rouen
le ministre de l'intérieur venu rendre
hommage au père hamel assassiné par deux
terroristes
il y a trois ans jour pour jour le 26
juillet 2016 alors qu'il s'apprêtait à
prononcer un discours pour la
commémoration du quatrième anniversaire
du drame le locataire de la place
beauvau a été interrompue l'emoa
darmanin salvio leur ont été préférés à
par plusieurs individus
au total onze personnes ont été
interpellées et auditionnées quatre sont
en garde à vue pour outrage
fonctionnaires
et on dirait que dans ce journal
l'avocat fabrice di vizio auteurs d'une
tribune la semaine dernière dans le jdd
pour appeler gérald darmanin et olivier
verront à la démission bonjour fabrice
di vizio merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france comment est-ce
que vous réagissez à ce qui s'est passé
tout à l'heure à saint-etienne du
rouvray acharnement d'une partie de la
population à l'encontre de gérald
darmanin ou accusations justifiant le
rappelle un ministre de l'intérieur
bénéficie de la présomption d'innocence
nous soyons bien d'accord
la présentation de gérard domaines comme
violeurs ce que j'ai entendu là est le
paroxysme du scandale non gérard manot
n'est pas un violeur tant qu'il n'a pas
été potentiellement déclaré coupable il
ne l'est pas je veux dire par cette
présentation 7 cette interpellation est
scandaleuse et elle tombe sur le coup de
la loi pénale et j'espère qu'elle
procure dans la publique poursuivra et
que le tribunal condamnera lourdement
des personnes qu'ils interpellent
publiquement qui que ce soit un ministre
qui que ce soit en le présentant comme
coupable avant qu'il ne soit jugé c'est
la définition exacte de l'atteinte à la
présomption d'innocence
ce qui n'a rien à voir avec la question
de la démission ou non de jardin manin
justement vous êtes l'auteur d'une
tribune récemment à l'encontre de gérald
darmanin selon vous les ministres qui
font l'objet d'une enquête tout comme
olivier verront d'ailleurs devraient
quitter leur poste
mais dans l'hypothèse d'une ministre de
l'intérieur ne seraient pas jugés
coupables comment est ce qu'il pourrait
se défaire de cette image je vais vous
poser la question différemment avec un
parallèle qui peu ou pas être surprenant
vous avez vu cette affaire de la
cathédrale de nantes avec effectivement
ce rwandais qui a était car reconnu
manifestement des faits des présumés
innocents
et pourtant il a été mis en détention
provisoire
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que l'argument tiré de la présomption
d'innocence est un argument qui n'a
aucun fondement
la présomption d'innocence elle n'a
jamais empêché de mettre des gens en
détention provisoire
elle a jamais empêché de mettre des gens
sont cons
10 hier elle n'a jamais empêché d
coercition ici le débat n'est pas celui
de la présomption d'innocence
on fait dire à la présomption
d'innocence et je suis étonné dans la
bouche du garde des sceaux d'entendre ce
mot parce que la présomption d'innocence
c'est pas ça la présomption d'innocence
certain nombre de droits procéduraux et
en particulier sur le plan public de ne
pas être présentés comme coupables alors
qu'on ne le serait pas mais c'est tout
là vous voyez bien je leur dit la
détention provisoire elle est pourtant
normalement une atteinte à la
présomption d'innocence
et pourtant elle est permise néanmoins
l'auteur reste présumé innocent rien
dans le droit positif aujourd'hui
n'empêche mais un lieu macron de
démettre jardin man 1 et olivier derand
et rien sur le droit positif ne permet
effectivement d'invoquer la présomption
d'innocence
c'est un argument bidon de député à l'om
ont signé récemment une tribune de
soutien à gérald darmanin alors qu'ils
font eux mêmes l'objet d'accusations de
harcèlement sexuel et d'agression
sexuelle informations de capital il ya
deux jours est ce que les médias en font
trop
les médias font ce qu'ils ont à faire
c'est à dire informer la limite elle est
celle du droit tant que les médias et
moi je n'ai pas vu ça ne présente pas
gérard manot qui que ce soit comme
coupable des faits qui lui sont
reprochés
il est naturel que les médias
effectivement puisse s'interroger et
rendre compte d'un débat dont on voit
bien qu effectivement été un débat qui
est en train de prendre des proportions
assez importante mais ce que je voudrais
vous dire c'est la chose suivante vous
disiez pour moi j'ai rien darmanin
doivent démissionner comme olivier
derand non non non pardon - pas pour moi
mais pour emmanuel macron lui même c'est
quand même emmanuel macron à travers son
ancien ministre de la justice monsieur
bayrou qui a quand même fait faire une
loi sur la moralisation de la vie
publique et dans laquelle effectivement
reprenant les mots de jaurès il vient
appelé au choc de confiance démocratique
comment est-ce qu'on peut d'un côté nous
expliquer qu'il faut un choc de
confiance républicains et que les
combles et français doivent avoir
confiance dans leur est dû faire une loi
sur la moralisation de la vie publique
et de l'autre ne pas appliquer ces
règles à soi même c'est ça l'enjeu du
débat
l'enjeu du débat est dans le jeu de
confiance et escaut jours
oui la confiance d'un jardin manin est
suffisante pour qu'il demeure comment
olivier derand la réponse est non c'est
tout au fait c'est bien que la confiance
est elle est rompue c'est à dire que ça
va être dur pour gérald darmanin dans
son exercice de ministre de l'intérieur
alors je vais vous dire nous aurions pu
imaginer quelque chose qui finalement
aurait pu contenter un peu tout le monde
et notamment ce grand principe ce grand
choc de confiance dont parlait jean
jaurès dans son grand discours de 1903
il y avait effectivement la possibilité
de nommer jardin man un ministre mais un
poste somme toute moins sensible que ne
l'était celui de ministre de l'intérieur
on aurait pu parfaitement imaginer qu'il
demeure ministre à bercy et ne prennent
pas la fonction ministre de l'intérieur
pourquoi
et bien parce que c'est cette fonction
de ministre de l'intérieur elle expose
quand même de manière assez flagrant
c'est un ministère régalien
avec en plus le contrôle de la police le
contrôle des autorités d'en quête c'est
quand même jetés un soupçon sur cette
affaire qui quand même bien poser un
problème sur le plan de la confiance
démocratique
pareil pour olivier ferrand et est on
obligé alors que olivier vers ont fait
l'objet d'une information judiciaire
quand même pour abstention volontaire de
prendre les mesures propres à combattre
un sinistre de le garder au ministère de
la santé n'aurait pu imaginer de les
nommer à des postes moins sensible est
moins exposé de façon effectivement a
également respecter cette j'en veux dire
vraiment cette nécessaire confiance
complètement altérée
vous avez vu le taux d'abstention
colossal qui émaillent les élections
d'année en année nous avons besoin de
restaurer ce choc de confiance et ça
aurait été un signe fort envoyé à la
population
et permettez moi d'ajouter un dernier
point la présomption d'innocence nos
gouvernants de sans souci que
lorsqu'elle les concerne le e
c'est ça qui me fait sourire c'est que
la présomption d'innocence dont les dans
l'épreuve dans les prévenus de droit
commun les erreurs judiciaires qui
effectivement s'amoncellent des heures
judiciaire qui jalonnent la vie des
avocats et finalement des prévenus sa
personne s'y intéressent la présomption
d'innocence année un vocable que lorsque
c'est un ministre qui est concerné c'est
quand même singulier merci fabrice
division d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes avocat et
auteur d'une tribune dans le gie
des récemment mise en examen on l'a dit
à l'instant avec fabrice di vizio du
bénévole du diocèse de la cathédrale
saint-pierre et saint-paul de nantes
le suspect qui se dit soulagée apeurée
est dépassé a donc avoué devant le juge
d'instruction d'être à l'origine de
trois départs de feu la semaine dernière
il est placé en détention provisoire
chargé de la sécurité de l'édifice ce
rwandais de 39 ans avait été placé en
garde à vue dès le début des
investigations d'être remis en liberté
ses motivations restent inconnues n'a
aucun antécédent judiciaire
son avocat a pris la parole devant la
presse tout à l'heure son état d'esprit
vous l'avez entendu vous l'avez vu jeudi
qu'un genre de soulagement c'est
quelqu'un qui est effectivement à
pleurer et quelqu'un qui est en quelque
sorte dépassé je rentre pas dans les
détails mais vous pouvez imaginer
évidemment comment elle faisait
ressentir
olivier ferrand en appelle à la
vigilance de la jeunesse alors que
quiberon ferme aujourd'hui ses plages la
nuit après la découverte de 19 cas de co
vide concernant des jeunes âgés de 18 à
25 ans le ministre de la santé a
n'exclut pas la fermeture de certains
bars en cause la multiplication de
scènes festives nocturnes sont
distanciation sociale il annonce le
remboursement des tests pcr dans
certaines villes comme à nice il est
possible de se faire dépister dans la
rue isabelle ferrière avec fatoumata
maquis
passer un été en toute sécurité voilà le
souhait de la ville de nice depuis
quelques jours des unités mobiles ont
été installés dans les gares les centres
commerciaux et les quartiers populaires
de la ville comme ici place masséna très
fréquenté pendant la période estivale
objectif proposer un test de dépistage
gratuit sans ordonnance ni rendez vous
et il ya des touristes qui arrivent il y
à l'aéroport où nous organisons
désormais aussi des tests choses arriver
où nous devons être vigilants pour
justement qu'il n'y ait pas de nouveau
une remontée de la circulation du virus
il y à quelques tests positifs ces
derniers jours et donc je veux que nous
puissions les contenir tout de suite
dans la file d'attenté
touristes et niçois se pressent une
simple pièce d'identité une carte vitale
suffisent en moins de deux heures une
soixantaine de tests pcr sont réalisés
puis les résultats sont envoyées par
mail sous deux jours un dispositif qui
rassure et je pense que j'ai un bon gars
nice y était pour contrôler la personne
des fusions de corps vite j'ai de la
famille il ya ma famille qui sont au
maroc mais ici il ya seulement des amis
du coup il faut un petit peu prendre les
précautions pour qu'on puisse les
protéger aussi moi ce sera une garantie
pour un petit une petite période parce
qu'après on peut toujours tomber sur
quelqu'un qui est contamine ans
contaminée mais tant qu'à faire c'est
des choses qu'il faudrait refaire
presque tous les quinze jours
car la prudence reste de mise avec un
taux de reproduction du virus de 1,08
contre 1 20 55 la semaine dernière les
autorités sanitaires constatent une
hausse des tests positifs depuis le
déconfinement il ya quand même
un risque quand même plus élevé de
contamination et donc on voit bien que
ont repassé les taux de contamination
important par rapport à ces derniers un
jour c'est la semaine où on avait
quasiment que des tests négatifs
là on a quand même une proportion des
dispositifs tous les jours de plus en
plus importante cette initiative menée
conjointement avec trois laboratoires et
l' agence régionale de santé sera mené
jusqu'à la fin de l'été pour que niçois
et vacanciers puissent profiter de la
période estivale en toute sérénité
sérénité niçoise inquiétudes catalan la
circulation accrue du cornât virus dans
la région de barcelone inquiète paris le
gouvernement français recommande
d'éviter de se rendre en catalogne
depuis ce matin le royaume uni impose de
son côté aux passagers en provenance
d'espagne
une mise en quarantaine norvege impose
désormais elles aussi des restrictions
similaires
réponse de madrid la situation à je cite
sous contrôle les foyers étant localisés
et isolé et vacanciers souvent
contraints de se rendre dans les
aéroports pour voyager des lieux où les
dépistages se font sur la base du
volontariat en france une mesure jugée
irresponsable par de nombreux médecins
elle ce même si paris rend les tests
obligatoires du 1er août pour les
passagers en provenance de 16 pays
classé rouge
ben hassen chébili avec sébastien dufour
à l'aéroport de roissy charles de gaulle
comme dans le reste des aéroports en
france le contrôle des passagers
arrivant des pays étrangers et difficile
à mettre en place les aéroports
apparaître comme le maillon faible de la
lutte contre le choral un virus dans
l'ensemble des aéroports les hôpitaux de
paris et la rs ont mis en place des
zones de dépistage des zones de
dépistage sur la base du volontariat
alors pourquoi sur la base du
volontariat et comment contrôler les
personnes venues de pays surtout classée
zone rouge
c'est un trafic aérien ont ralenti qui a
repris à l'aéroport de roissy charles de
gaulle depuis la réouverture des
frontières il ya un peu plus d'un mois
des passagers du monde entier accueillis
dans ce terminal 2e
dans lequel est installé un stand de
dépistage depuis le 12 juillet dernier
des tests qu à notre grande surprise
n'ont rien d'obligatoire ici en fait les
passagers arrivent de la zone
internationale
la première
ce qui vaut à ses le centre de tests peu
vide il passe ici ils sont inscrits
administrativement sur l'offre
logicielle pour le laboratoire et
ensuite ils sont testés
donc c'est bien sûr la base du
volontariat c'est bien sûr la base du
volontariat tant qui a pas d'évolution
de la réglementation
comment ça se fait que ça a été mis en
place aussi tardive - là que les
frontières ouvertes by ap plus d'un mois
alors moi je suis opérateur donc
on est là php nous on vient tester si
ces questions là on n'en saura pas plus
contacté par rt france les responsables
de l' agence régionale de santé n'ont
jusqu'ici jamais été en mesure de
répondre précisément à cette question au
terminal 2e on ne se bouscule pas pour
se faire dépister pour réaliser ces
tests
une trentaine de personnes le matin et
autant le soir des étudiants de médecine
pour la plupart mobilisés pour
l'occasion
parmi les candidats au test tristan de
retour de barcelone
après un rapide entretien dans un espace
dédié place au dépistage qui ne durera
que quelques secondes
désagréable
tristan aura ses résultats dans les 48
heures d'ici là il est libre d'aller où
bon lui semble selon aéroports de paris
400 à 600 tests pcr sont ainsi réalisés
chaque jour pour les quelques 20 mille
passagers qui arrivent quotidiennement
deux pays classé rouge
pour les autres une simple prise de
température suffit beaucoup d'entre eux
avoue d'ailleurs ne pas avoir été testé
à leur arrivée
j'arrive de téhéran est en fait il ya
juste des contrôles des prises de
température sur automatique par les
caméras c'est bien de san francisco et
on a été contrôlé parce que j'ai dit oui
au contest mais je ne souhaitais pas
obligé je viens de las vegas et on nous
laisse l'option 2
passé le test du coc vide ou non
pourtant près de huit mille nouveaux cas
ont été recensés en france ces deux
dernières semaines
c'est sans doute la raison pour laquelle
le gouvernement va rendre obligatoire
d'ici le 1er août prochain
les tests pour les passagers en
provenance de 16 pays jugés à risque
comme israël les émirats arabes unis ou
encore le brésil
une mesure tardive que bon nombre de
médecins français jugent aujourd'hui
insuffisante
ils réclament la mise en quarantaine
automatique de tous les voyageurs
entrant sur le territoire français rien
ne remplace en termes d'efficacité
épidémiologique j'entends je m'exprime
en tant que médecin une quarantaine
je vous avoue que j'ai du mal à
comprendre ce qui se passe
d'autant plus qu'on a quand même
monsieur déconfinement qui est quand
même théoriquement censé connaître son
métier puisque c'est lui qui s'occupe
des du confinement qui est maintenant
premier ministre donc je pense qu'il est
quand même parfaitement informés ou
alors c'est à désespérer de ce qui se
passe dans notre beau pays de france
en effet les signes d'une recrudescence
de l'épidémie sont là +12 5% de test
positif + 27 % de contamination sur le
territoire alors que les compagnies
aériennes continuent d'ouvrir un nombre
toujours plus important de vols les
conséquences de la réouverture des
frontières semble insuffisamment prise
au sérieux par les pouvoirs publics
le mouvement black line rider ne faiblit
pas aux états unis illustration à
seattle cette ville de la côte ouest
rejoint la contestation initiée
importante ville de la côte pacifique
également
et épicentre de la contestation elle
nouveau rassemblement la nuit dernière
pour dénoncer les brutalités policières
deux mois après la mort de jack floyd un
afro-américain asphyxié par un policier
blanc
les manifestants demandent le départ des
agents fédéraux déployés par une bonne
part donald trump ou rétablir le calme
le président américain est en difficulté
dans les sondages à 100 jours de
l'élection présidentielle
en toile de fond le mouvement de la
classe amateur donc mais aussi la crise
sanitaire il lui reste un peu plus de
trois mois pour relancer sa campagne
avant le 3 novembre
robin pu elle c'est une campagne
présidentielle inédite qui se déroule
outre atlantique avec la crise du
coronavirus la course à la maison
blanche a pris une nouvelle tournure
alors que les états unis sont le pays le
plus touché par l'épidémie
donald trump est fragilisée pour avoir
minimisé sa gravité dans l'espoir d'être
réélu mais ces derniers jours le
président a fait volte face sur le port
du masque
face à l'ampleur de l'épidémie donald
trump a décidé d'annuler la convention
républicaine qui devait se tenir en
floride
aujourd'hui le locataire de la maison
blanche poursuit sa campagne dans un
contexte sanitaire compliqué nous allons
faire d'autres choses des meetings
télévisés et en ligne pendant la semaine
dont nous parlons ce qui sera très bien
je pense que nous allons faire ça bien
je ferai quand même un discours de
conventions sous une forme différente
mais nous n'aurons pas de grosses
convention bondée à proprement parler ce
n'est simplement pas le bon moment pour
ça nous demandons à tous les américains
d'être vigilant de respecter la
distanciation social de porter un masque
de faire tout ce qui est nécessaire pour
nous débarrasser de cette horrible
situation un manque de réactivité face
aux coronavirus qui se ressent dans
l'opinion selon les derniers sondages le
président sortant accuse un retard de
huit à dix points sur son rival joe
biden à la télévision américaine le
candidat démocrate point de l'attitude
et les contradictions de donald trump
ils m'ont simplement sur les faits il
ment simplement sur ce qui se passe il
dit que tout le monde peut être testée
maintenant nous n'avons pas besoin de
tests
il s'assure que les taux
d'hospitalisation ne soient pas signalés
aux centres pour le contrôle et la
prévention des maladies
ils le sont qu'au ministère de la santé
où en fait il y à des nominations
politiques il a évincé tout les
enquêteurs internes et a dit que nous
n'en avions pas besoin
c'est ridicule il est donc responsable
et il a essentiellement agiter le
drapeau blanc
il a dit je ne suis pas responsable je
n'ai pas le faire toute la
responsabilité revient au gouverneur
malgré un ballotage favorable la vence
de joe biden reste fragile l'ancien
vice-président de barack obama doit
encore choisir une colistière un choix
politique qui pourrait modifier sa
perception dans l'opinion à son jour du
vote
tout reste possible gérald olivier est
l'auteur de sur la route de la maison
blanche aux éditions jean picollec pour
ce spécialiste de la politique
américaine beaucoup de choses peuvent se
passer en ce jour la campagne de joe
biden pour l'instant se limite à
dénoncer de nature et la volonté des
démocrates c'est de faire que l'élection
en novembre soit véritablement un
référendum non pas sur la politique de
donald trump
mais sur la personne de dan haren donc
le sujet d'élections aujourd'hui c'est
un night-shop hebeisen quand il
intervient c'est pour attaquer le
président en place il va revenir un
moment où joe biden devait devra comment
dire sortir de sa câble a actuellement
il est dans son best man qu'il est chez
lui il est confiné en grande partie
lorsqu'il sort il sort masqué il donne
deux trois petites conférences sans
répondre aux questions en direct et à un
moment il va devoir annoncer un
programme annoncé ce que lui ferait
rappelons que il plas 40 ans
d'expérience politique et qu'il a passé
36 ans de sa vie au sénat donc si vous
voulez faire des choses il a eu le temps
de le faire
il ya un moment où il va devoir
s'engager ne serait ce que pour décider
de sa colistière dont vous parliez
également et à ce moment là c'est lui
qui deviendra attaquable et c'est à ce
moment là où les choses pour un petit
peu se rééquilibrer
hichem mais chichi nouveau premier
ministre en tunisie il a été nommé hier
soir par le président kaïs sayyed
l'ex ministre de l'intérieur a un mois
pour former son gouvernement
il devra obtenir la confiance du
parlement à la majorité absolue d'ici
septembre en cas d'échec l'assemblée
sera dissoute et de nouvelles élections
législatives auront lieu le jem et
chichi s'est exprimé hier monsieur le
président de la république m'a honoré
aujourd'hui en me désignant pour former
le gouvernement
et ça témoigne d'une confiance dont je
suis fier et pour laquelle je le
remercie en effet cette confiance est
une grande responsabilité et un grand
défi à relever surtout dans les
circonstances particulières par
lesquelles passe le pays nous veillons
sur la formation d'un gouvernement à la
hauteur des attentes des tunisiens et
qui répondra à leurs revendications
légitimes qu'ils attendaient durant
toutes ces années
que dieu nous aide pour le bien de ce
pays
vive la tunisie libre et résistante à
jamais un retour à présent sur
l'actualité de la semaine marquée par la
première prière musulmane vendredi dans
l'ex basilique byzantine sainte-sophie
en présence de richie tayyip erdogan
édifice emblématique d'istanbul monument
jusque-là musée redevient mosquée la
demande du président turc
un changement de statut controversé rv à
paris c'est la première grande prière
pour les musulmans dans l'ex basilique
sainte-sophie reconverti en mosquée
covit 19 oblige seules quelques
centaines de personnes était autorisée
dans l'enceinte de l'édifice construit
au 6e siècle en avant lors de la
cérémonie
recep tayyip erdogan coiffé d'une
calotte est agenouillé sous la
majestueuse coupole aujourd'hui était
très très importants pour réaliser le
désir de notre peuple qui remonte à des
décennies selon les chiffres officiels
que je viens de recevoir 350 mille
personnes ont assisté à la prière du
vendredi
une décision vivement critiquée par la
grèce qui y voient une provocation
envers l'occident et la religion
orthodoxe vendredi soir quelques heures
après la première prière dans l'ex
basilique byzantine les églises grecques
au mur drapeaux en berne et des
manifestants ont même brûlé des drapeaux
turcs pour protester contre la
reconversion de l'ancienne basilique
sainte-sophie en mots ce qu'est ce qui
se passe à istanbul n'est pas une
démonstration de puissance mais une
preuve de faiblesse
ils n'ont certainement pas le pouvoir
d'éclipser le rayonnement d'un site du
patrimoine mondial
mais les valeurs universelles ont été
ternies et c'est pourquoi elle nécessite
une condamnation universelle des propos
qu'elle a immédiatement répondu le porte
parole du ministère des affaires
étrangères turc a mis aksoy les enfants
gâtés de l'europe qui ne peuvent pas
accepter qu'on se prosternent à nouveau
à gué à sofia sont en plein délire avec
sainte sophie
une nouvelle étape est franchie dans les
relations déjà très tendues entre la
grèce et la turquie
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
votre attention se retrouve d'ici une
trentaine de minutes pour un nouveau
point complet sur l'actualité on se
donne donc rendez vous à 21h
d'ici là évidemment sur arte français
place à nos magazines d'information
[Musique]
le grave incident du dis-je entre une
frégate française et des navires de
combat turc doit nous faire prendre
conscience de l'évolution inquiétant de
la situation en méditerranée orientale
nous sommes confrontés un président
tuerie qui résonne exclusivement en aura
pas de sens qui considère l'europe comme
un adversaire qu'il a toujours réussi à
faire plier en pariant qu'il n'y aura
jamais d escalade avec des alliés il
continue à affirmer une ligne
diplomatico militaire indépendant par
rapport à ses alliés de l'otan tout en
se déclarant un membre totalement fiable
de cet organisme
la négociation sera difficile avec un
interlocuteur qui n'hésite pas à se
mettre sur la ligne rouge pour forcer le
destin
[Musique]
le pôle it a été le révélateur
le monstre aux pieds d'argile que nous
sommes la france élite 1 elle veut
devenir veut partout mais on n'a pas les
moyens
ma critique et d'un de ce que notre
continuant à nier l'évidence c'est à
dire de continuer à mentir sur la
réalité de notre pouvoir qui est devenu
comme des autres dom est-ce que cette
france-là bouffer moins peur que celle
que vous avez décrypte cet internement
de la france dont j'ai peur c'est 2 du
ca qui pourrait